por dios y por la patria sí juro
sergio massa ya es super ministro de
argentina
juramento como titular de economía
también supervisará agricultura fomento
y relaciones con organismos
internacionales y delinea su plan para
estabilizar la economía argentina
asegurando que el programa de ajustes
cumplirá con las cuestionadas exigencias
del fmi
vamos a cumplir con la meta del 2,5 del
déficit primario del sistema público
nacional
establecida con el presupuesto que
tuvimos que sacar luego del rechazo del
congreso
vamos a hacer todas las correcciones
necesarias para ahorrar nuestra palabra
empeñada su principal reto será detener
la caída libre económica cuando es el
tercer ministro de economía en un mes
sucede en el cargo a silvina batakis
quien fue durante tres semanas el
reemplazo de martín guzmán cuestionado
por el kirchnerismo y valedor del
acuerdo con el fmi esta es vista como la
última oportunidad del presidente
alberto fernández para detener la
hemorragia económica es un tiempo para
que todos con mucha esperanza unamos
esfuerzos
para salir adelante en medio de
constantes protestas sergio massa deberá
solucionar el problema de la inflación
en junio se ubicó en un 62% interanual y
ha afectado al aumento de precios al
consumidor que se espera que aumente en
un 70% este año para ello tratará de
bajar el déficit fiscal captar divisas
mediante incentivos a la exportación y
préstamos internacionales
varios falta comida